you jakesully I'd like to talk to you
about a fresh start on a new world you'd
be making a difference
I became a ringing for the hardship told
myself I can pass any test of making
past
it was a single thing worth fighting for
ladies and gentlemen
you're not in Kansas anymore
on Pandora
you should see your faces
there beyond that fence we have an
indigenous population called the Navi
this is why we're here because this
little gray rock sells for twenty
million a kilo their village happens to
be resting on the richest deposit and
they need to relocate you're supposed to
be finding a diplomatic solution the
concept is to drive these remotely
controlled bodies called avatars they
grown from human DNA mixed with DNA of
the natives marine in an avatar body
that's a won't mix you get me what I
need I'll see to it you get your legs
bent your real legs
yes sir looks like you this is your
avatar
just relax let your mind go blank it
shouldn't be hard for you
kick it's real simple
I want you to learn from the inside I
want you to gain their trust
you should not be here
go back
well this is your fault I need your help
outstanding
haven't gotten lost in the woods have
you you forget what team you're playing
for
strong prey on the weak nobody doesn't
think you've got one hour we knew this
would happen
pretty changed Jake it's crazy here the
four rich has taken over he's ruling
I guess we'd better stop him
they sent us a message that they can
take whatever they want
we will send them a message
this is all left
[Music]